[音楽]
皆様何のために働いていますか
皆さんにとって働く意味って何ですか
学校を卒業してこれから自立しなきゃと会社に入っていっ
早く仕事を覚えようと朝から晩までがむしゃらに働いていっ
いろんな仕事がそのうちにできるようになってきて気づけば部下がいて
人間としても成長しようと一生懸命努力し続けてきた
でもふと
俺って何の為に働いてんだろう
そんな風に思ったことはありませんか
ある調査によると72%の人が働く意味を見失ったという経験があるそうです
そしてみんな口を揃えて言うそうです
お金のためだけに働くのは嫌だ
もっと社会に貢献できていると実感できる仕事がしたいと
でも現実問題生活は大切
だから給料を減らせない
社会貢献は老後にだってできるし
稼いだお金で寄付することだってできる
だから今はやっぱり一生懸命稼ぐことの方が大切
そう分かっちゃいるんだけどやっぱり何だかモヤモヤしたものが心のどこかに残っ
ちゃってる
そんなことってありませんか
ここで皆さんにちょっと質問です
もしこんな問題が皆さんの目の前にあったら
みなさんはどうしますか
日本に来た外国人が部屋を貸してもらえない
外国人はルールを守らないうるさい
保証人が建てられない
いろんな理由で外国人の入居費が起こっていました
さて皆さんならどうしますか
一緒に不動産屋を回って部屋探しを手伝ってあげますか
禁酒差別だとどっかに訴えますか
せっかく日本に来てくれた外国人が部屋を貸してもらえない
もう最悪ですよね
僕は頭にきて
だったら僕が家賃保証するからその上で僕は代わりにお家さんの代わりに僕が外国人の
みなさんに家を貸したらいいですよねと爽やさに話をしました
そして留学生の人たち話を聞いてみると
みんなこう言いました
日本人の友達が欲しい
確かにせっかく日本に来てアパートに一人暮らしは寂しいですよね
だから僕たちは日本人と外国人が半分半分で一緒に暮らすシェアハウスを作ることにし
ました
僕らがこの事業を始めた8年前はシェアハウスっていう言葉すら理解してもらえません
でしたが
今では東京都内に72ハウス
大阪と京都所司て韓国台湾合わせて約120ハウスを運営しています
今まで47カ国約4千人以上がこのシェアハウスにしに行っ
同じ釜の飯を食い一生の友人に出会い
今では単なる住居問題を超えた価値を見出しています
次に
こんな問題に出会いました
ミャンマーの農家さんが生活に苦しんでいる
この村は陰で村と言って約250世帯ほどが暮らす
ミャンマーの小さな村なんですが農家さんのほとんどが葉巻タバコの栽培をしています
天木こういう天きたわけですねや巻きタバコは
葉っぱに穴が空いちゃうと商品価値が落ちちゃうので
みんな虫がつかないように大量の農薬を撒くんですね
だから農薬による健康被害もたくさん起きています
農薬や肥料といった栽培コストはどんどん上がっていくのに書いてある金額は下がる
一方なんです
仲買人からの借金はかさむ一方で生活が苦しく
タイに出稼ぎに行った15歳の息子とは連絡が取れないん
そんな人たちもたくさんいました
尊重をはじめ村の人たちはみんなどうにかこの状況から抜け出したいと強く願ってい
ました
でもどうしたらいいかわからないと
さて皆さんならどうしますか
僕たちは葉巻タバコの代わりにハーブのオーガニック栽培を提案しました
仲買人たちとも話をして僕らが借金の立て替え払いをする代わりにこの村から手を引い
てもらいました
村の一角に土地を借りてハーブのテスト栽培をしてどんな品種のハーブがどのぐらい
収穫できるか確認しました
有機農法の専門家を採用して村の人たち1からオーガニック栽培のやり方教えてきまし
た
他にも移動をつくったり収穫したハーブをドライしてカットしたりする工場も作りまし
でも問題はここからです
農家さんたちが作ってくれたハーブの買取保証するんですがそれをどうやって売るか
安売りはできません
彼らからの買取品価格が安くなっちゃ意味がないですから
でもそんなことより一番問題は日本人はハーブティーなんか誰ももんじゃないってこと
です
皆さんだってコーヒーやお茶は毎日飲んでると思うんですけど
羽生ティーなんか当たれものはないですよね
簡単に言うとマーケットがないと
さて困ったぞと
結論から言うと
僕らのこのハーブ事業は2014年燃焼8.4億円になりました
この5年間で88万人のお客さんに使ってもらい今では年間30トン
インレー村約160世帯分相当のハブを輸入するようになりました
さてどうやって行ったのか
僕らは
妊娠中と授乳中専用のハーブティを作りました
この2年間は河川を控えるのでお茶とかコーヒーを飲まなくなるんですね
そして母乳不足といったこの式ならではの悩みもありました
だから僕たちは日本の助産師さんとイギリスのメディカルハーブアリストに協力をお
願いして
そんなママたちのためのハーブティを共同開発しました
こうやってできたハーブティーは妊婦さんや産後ママの間で口コミでどんどん広がって
いて
今では日本全国の産婦人科病院の15%で配られるようになりました
昨年は楽天のショップオブザイヤーにも選ばれました
さて最後の問題です
アジア最貧国の1つと呼ばれるバングラディッシュ
本当に貧しい人がたくさんいます彼らの力になりたい
でも日本の約4割ほどの面積に1億5000万人が暮らすこの国は先ほどのミャンマー
とは違い
十分な土地はありません
あらゆるところでお米が作られていて米の生産量は世界4位です
それでもお金がお米が足りなくて輸入に侵入している
そんな中終電を潰してハーブをつくりましょうとは言えませんよね
今度は土地がない
さて皆さんならどうしますか
僕らが注目したのは牛です
イスラム教では年に2回移動と呼ばれる技術祭があって
裕福な家庭では一家に1と牛を捧げるんですね
そして日頃肉を食べられないような貧しい人たちも分け与えるという
そんなことをやるんですけれども
1億5000万人いる国民の約9割が
イスラム教徒のバングラディシュでは大勢の牛がささげられます
もちろん食されるわけですけれどもその後に残る大量の厩肥
僕らはそこに注目しました
このバングラディッシュにある資源牛革を使った製品工場をつくって貧しい人たちの
雇用を作ろうと思いました
日本の革職人さんに技術を教えてもらって始めた自社工場は2年間で300名を超える
人たちを雇用できるようになりました
いまご荘櫂したものは全て僕らの会社で行っている事業の一部です
日本韓国台湾ミャンマーバングラディッシュ
世界5カ国7拠点で約500人が働いています
ボランティアではありません
みんな仕事としてこの社会問題に取り組んでいます
だから
稼ぐことと社会貢献は両立できる
そう僕は思っています
そして今皆さんに聴いていただいて分かってもらったように特別なことは何もしてませ
ん
問題を見つけて解決するという
どのマーケターも当たり前にやっていることを僕らは社会問題に対してやっているだけ
なんです
だから正直に言いますこのてレックスの登壇
僕はずっと断っていたんです
人前で話をするような特別なことは何もしていないしまだ何も成し遂げてない分際で
人前に出ていたそうに話しをするなんて
泣かずかしいじゃないですか
そんな恥さらしやだと
でもスタッフの方がどうしても出ろというんです
困ったもんですしつこいんです
みんな何のために
働くのかとすごくモヤモヤしてるからあんたの花やお話を聞かせたいと
でもそんな事言ったら
僕だってずっとモヤモヤしてんですね
でもモヤモヤしているって事はそこから抜け出したいっていう証拠じゃないですか
何かやりたいことがあるって言うことだと思うんですすごく良いこと
だからそのモヤモヤをもっと大切にしないといけない
そしてそのも家にもモヤモヤに向かって一歩を踏み出さないといけない
でもそうした瞬間多くの人がガチッと固まっちゃうんです
お金を取るか
社会貢献を取るか
やりたいことを取るか
家族を取るか
何を選択するかで
悩み出すそして何も選択せずに終わる
そんな人をたくさん見ました見てきました
でも全部やったらいいじゃないですか
何かを選んでなにかを諦めなければいけない
そんなこと誰が言ったんですか
僕は全部できると思っています
だって全部やりたいじゃないですか
こんなこと言うと精神論みたいですがこれは精神論ではなくて事実なんです
全部やりたいという自分の事実
ここから目を背けちゃいけない
あとはどうやったらできるかだけを考えるんです
すぐに難しいというのはなしにしましょう
一般的にはとか
普通はとか
言うのもやめましょう
それらは全部やらない為の言い訳探しに過ぎないからです
変な枠に当てはめて考えるのもやめましょう
ビジネスは利潤を追求するものだ社会貢献を儲からない家族を取るか仕事を取るか
でもそれって本当ですか
今話をしたようにビジネスと社会貢献の両立だってできるんです
僕バリバリ働いていますけれども朝も夜も一緒に家族とご飯食べますよ
家族第一ですけど仕事も第一です
自分の人生なんですか
特価の評論家みたいにつまんない枠に当てはめて話をそらすのはもうやめましょう
自分が本当にやりたいところに向かって
進んでいきましょう
でもそんなこと言うと
そんな現実は甘くないっ
思うかもしれません
それあんたはできるかもしれんけどやっぱり理想論やねと
確かに簡単なことではないのかもしれません
でも
ここにいる誰も否定できない事実が一つだけあります
それは僕らは毎日刻一刻としに向かって近づいていってるという事実です
僕が今ここで話している10分という時間は間違いなくしに向かって近づいた10分な
んです
だから僕は
心の中のモヤモヤをもっと大切にした方がいいと本当に思うんです
だっても病を残したまま後悔しながら死ぬのは嫌じゃないですか
僕は田口が生まれてきたからこの世の中少し良くなったねって言われて死にたいと思っ
ています
だからこんなもんじゃ終われない
多くの人を助けたいと多くの社会問題に貢献したいと思っています
だからちまちまやってちゃいけない
最低でも1兆円ぐらいの規模でやらないといけないと本当に思っています
だからどうしたらそれができるかすごくモヤモヤしています
僕という枠組みを超えないとダメだこのままのスピードじゃダメだと思いました
だから会社のあり方も変えました
今ではこの会社にはたくさんの社長たちがいます
みんな自分はこんな社会問題を解決したいという夢を持ってきてこの会社を利用して
その夢を実現する
そんな社会起業家のプラットフォームのような会社に変えました
だから僕はたくさんいる社長の一人になりました
そうやって僕たちは今少しずつ大きなインパクトを見始めました
世界の人たちを助けたいと
遊牧のビジョン
僕という枠組みを取り払った瞬間一気に現実味を帯び始めました
だから形なんてどうだっていいんです
皆さんも変な枠組みにあてはめてやらない言い訳をするのはやめましょう
難しいとできないは違うんです
難しくてもできなくはないんです
だから心の中のマヤマヤに向かって
一歩を踏み出していきましょうそして
もし選択に迷ったらよかったらこの言葉を思い出してください
二世の価値は何を得るかではなく
何を残すかにある
これは僕のモットーです
なんでもかんでも得ようとするから選択がややこしくなるんだと思います
でも人生は何を得るかではないと思います
どうせ死んだら何をもっていけないんですでも残してはいける
だから何を残すかが人生の本当の価値だと思うんです
こうやって考えるとシンプルに一歩を踏み出せるんじゃないかなと思います
心の中にあるモヤモヤをお互い大切にこれからも頑張っていきましょう
そして私たち一人ひとりが素敵な何かを残せるように頑張りましょう
私たち一人ひとりが何かを一つずつ残していければこの社会はどんどん良くなっていき
ます
みんなでそんな素敵な社会をつくっていきましょう
ありがとうございました
[拍手]
[音楽]